just test test can you hear me get your
hairy whisper a plant attack at this
altitude
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking so no else
your personal question now it is soon
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by LinkedIn jobs hiring
can be hard can be super super expensive
and very painful if you get it wrong I
certainly have had that experience
multiple times I've made a lot of
mistakes I am NOT eager to repeat any of
them so I try to do as much vetting as
possible now on the front end today with
more qualified candidates than ever but
certainly more noise than ever employers
need a hiring solution that helps them
find the right people for their
businesses without wasting time without
wasting money LinkedIn jobs provides
just that LinkedIn jobs screens
candidates with the hard and soft skills
that you specify that you're looking for
so you can quickly find and hire the
right person they also look beyond work
skills so collaboration creativity
adaptability to connect you with
candidates who match your business
perfectly they have nearly endless
business specific data points that help
them to massage this and that which can
help you to find the best fit LinkedIn
can make sure your job post gets in
front of people you want to hire people
with the skills qualifications and other
insights that help LinkedIn paint a
better picture of potential candidates
it's no wonder the great candidates are
hired every eight seconds on average on
LinkedIn that's pretty wild every eight
seconds so find the right person meant
for your business today with LinkedIn
jobs you can pay what you want and the
first $50 is on LinkedIn just visit
linkedin.com slash to him for more
details
again that's linkedin.com slash Tim to
get $50 off your first job post let's
check it out
linkedin.com slash Tim Terms and
Conditions to apply
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books I've been talking about fresh
books for years now the all-in-one
invoicing payments and accounting
solution many entrepreneurs I know as
well as many contractors and freelancers
I work with all the time use it all the
time so I get to see fresh books on a
weekly basis fresh books makes it super
easy to track things like expenses
project time and client info and then
merge it all into great-looking invoices
fresh books can save users up to 200
hours per year on accounting and
bookkeeping tasks I don't know about you
but I like to do as little of that as
possible so 200 hours is a lot of hours
fresh books is always releasing new
features that make running your business
easier and here's just a few of the
major upgrades they've made in the last
12 months alone number one they've
redesigned the time tracking feature to
create a more intuitive time tracking
experience number two they know just how
frustrating bank reconciliation can be
so they've automated bank reconciliation
removing the pain number three they've
added ACH bank transfers that means you
now have an even faster way to collect
payment from your clients it's easy to
see how fresh books can grow with your
business and also help your business
grow just gives you more time to focus
on growing the business as opposed to
running the business and the admin stuff
they have plans to match your needs no
matter the size of your business
from the basic to comprehensive from
small to big and it all starts at just
15 dollars per month right now they're
offering it my listeners that's you guys
a free 30-day trial of fresh books you
can try it out with no credit card no
credit card is required just go to fresh
books.com slash to him and enter tim
ferriss that's two hours to us as in the
how did you hear about us section that's
fresh books com slashed him and enter
Tim Ferriss in the how did you hear
about us section check it out fresh
books calm slash Tim
well hello boys and girls ladies and
germs this is Tim Ferriss welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is my job to sit down with
world-class performers of all different
types to tease out the habits routines
favorite books etc that you can apply
and test in your own life this time we
have a slightly different episode I do
not claim to be a world-class performer
but it is a Q&A with yours truly long
ago not that long ago I tested a fan
supported model earlier in the year in
place of sponsors but I ended up with
reverting back to ads it's a long story
if you want to read about it and the
findings and so on you can just go to
tim dot blog forward slash podcast
experiment but after the experiment
ended i offered an additional live Q&A
with supporters people who've been
paying every month to support the
podcast as a way to say thanks and that
is the audio of this particular episode
cover a lot of topics abundance mindset
balding you may have noticed that i am
rather bald these days and the process
getting there what was that like how i
think about building a legacy if i think
about it at all
how to improve verbal tics lyme disease
cultivating gratitude the grieving
process my morning routine that's the
morning mor not mo you our morning
routine went on book deadline and much
more i do mention a book that i was
working on at the time that I have since
cancelled which was ironically enough
circularly enough a book about saying no
so I said no to the book on no and
that's really about it one housekeeping
note there were a few small glitches in
the audio which is always a risk of live
QA but we cleaned it up and should be
a-okay to listen to so without further
ado please enjoy this very wide-ranging
episode with Tim Ferriss
first and foremost thanks so much to
everyone for attending if you are
attending this live you are a small and
elite force of supporters who chose to
support the podcast and my other
activities in these short-lived fans
supported experiment so thank you for
that and we are doing a bonus live video
Q&A just for that group and that's you
guys so thanks so much and I'm excited
to do this I am working on a new book I
am going booze free from Monday to
Friday evening and then I'm allowed to
have a little bit of booze which I do
use for writing I try to follow the
Ernest Hemingway write drunk in my case
only partially drunk two nights a week
Friday Saturday and at it's over it's a
right drunk edit sober that's Hemingway
mine is a little more constrained and
today we're going to do live questions
and we will also do questions that have
been submitted by all of you I have a
few pages printed out I've selected a
handful that I'm going to tackle and
we'll go back and forth so we'll do 20
minutes of submitted questions and then
20 minutes of live 20 minutes submitted
etc back and forth the wine may affect
my perception of time so we'll see how
that goes let's just jump right into it
question number one is from Justin you
mentioned verbal tics in your last Q&A
did you always speak as well as you
currently do answer no if not what are
the things you did to improve in truth
see here we go it's just this placebo
effect of this half glass of wine that
I've had what did you do to improve your
extemporaneous speaking that's a hard
word both on the podcast and Q&A
sessions like this number one is record
yourself this is true for skill
improvement whether it's sports related
language related that could be primary
or secondary or tertiary language you
need a record that you can analyze so
record yourself talking that could be
over dinner with friends it could be in
an interview format does not have to be
for publication and that will highlight
many of the habits that you have which
could be words or phrases that are used
for fillers like like you know like you
know is another one or let's see would
be one let's see so was one of my
favorites and there are words that you
may use as crutches or very frequently I
used pretty the adverb pretty that's
pretty good that's pretty bad that's
pretty expensive that's pretty this
pretty that one of the ways that I
forced myself to address that
specifically was by adding [ __ ] after
pretty so whenever I said that's pretty
I was obligated to say [ __ ] expensive
that's pretty [ __ ] irritating that's
pretty [ __ ] whatever and that mental
hijack of sorts that interrupts helped
me to tone down my use pretty very
dramatically writing helps to improve
your speaking if you for instance
developed a habit of identifying
sentences that are trying to do too much
and breaking them into multiple
sentences looking at transcripts of
yourself speaking is very helpful those
are a few of the remedies that come to
mind and we all have things to work on
but there are generally some low-hanging
fruit that you can tackle right off the
bat and it starts with recording and/or
looking at a transcript next question I
have no idea how to pronounce this
Mikkel see GNA have all recently did an
epic tweet storm on how to get rich what
would Tim's answer be on how to build
wealth I think I would generally agree
with Scott Adams the creator of Dilbert
and I'll paraphrase certainly don't mean
to speak for him but I select projects
based on predominantly skill acquisition
skills I'll develop or acquire and
relationships
that I will either foster or develop
from scratch that will transcend the
project I'm working on this is very
important because what I'm trying to
ensure is that I can win over time even
if the project fails so when I choose
different projects I'm looking at
opportunities that will help me to
develop relationships with people who
hopefully I would enjoy spending time
with who are awesome or what they do who
I could work with for my entire life
and that's certainly a navall ism if you
wouldn't work with them for ten minutes
don't work with them or if you wouldn't
work with them forever don't work with
them for ten minutes is one of his
Maxim's so to speak something along
those lines and I tend to agree with
that symbolically more than literally of
course
and what that allows you to do is over
time to accumulate skills and
relationships that can be applied to
many different things and when you
develop relationships with let's just
say ten people who are all a list
capable in their field a listers tend to
know other a listers across industries
so you don't need to know a person in
every industry if you know one really
incredible say designer meaning designer
for web applications they will know
other a players in the the stack so to
speak related to developing a product
they may know also a tier investors who
happen to specialize in the space and so
on if you know a top tier photographer
say who works in fashion and travel they
will know then eight year players who
are models who are agents who are
publicists who are fill in the blank and
that is to say you don't need to collect
a hundred business cards in your pocket
to build a fantastic Network you really
just need to develop relationships with
people a you really like and who like
you spending time with you say over wine
or meals and to cultivate those over
time and part of the way to do that is
by having them over
with your projects would be involved
with opportunities you choose and that
is really the trek if there is a trick
that's that's that's one of them the
second would be cap your downside or
define your downside and you could look
at the story of Richard Branson and
Virgin Atlantic how that was started and
how he negotiated for instance with
Boeing I believe it was to return planes
that were leased if things didn't work
out and so he was able to cap the
maximum financial downside and as soon
as you can do that and you understand
your worst case scenario and can
hopefully quantify it then the upside
very often takes care of itself that's
not true in relationships but meaning
intimate or personal relationships the
upside does not take care of itself but
in business that can be hardwired or
enabled to have an advantage a
comparative advantage in playing through
say informational advantage which I had
for early-stage startups when I lived in
Silicon Valley so those those be a few
thoughts next question
Charles Johnson what core concepts and
philosophies would you teach your
hypothetical child so she could 10x your
success what definition of success did
you just use I don't like this word
success because it's so overused to have
become meaningless now there is no
agreed-upon definition and that makes
conversations using that word very
dangerous also drew with words like god
or you name it there are there dozens
and hundreds and thousands of these
words that are routinely used but if you
were to look at two or three people
having an awful violent debate about
something or just a heated debate about
one of these words if you asked each of
them how they define the term they would
be different so they're having different
conversations in their own heads
fighting with empty jackets in a sense
so that's pointless success is really
not the word I would use but if I wanted
her and in this case since you used she
to be highly capable and intelligent in
the sense if we want to look at general
intelligence as the ability to adapt and
solve problems another way to think of
it would be to learn and solve problems
to be an autodidact then there are
really two key if we want to call it
concepts that I would focus on one is
actually more of a philosophical
framework and the second is more of a
toolkit but they reflect the micro and
macro in both directions and hopefully
I'll make clear what I mean by that the
first comes from a friend of mine Mike
maples jr. a very successful
entrepreneur and investor who's been on
the Midas list and I recall at one point
we were on a hike and I asked him what
advice he would give to a new parent or
someone thinking about becoming a parent
and we talked about quite a few things
but the one that stood out that I
mentioned now is he effectively said the
most important thing is to teach your
kids to be optimists to train them to be
optimists because without that you're
lost with the ability to see the silver
lining to see the benefits of even a
very dire situation you can at least
look for and see solutions and if you
conversely have a pessimistic lens you
could look at the same situation and see
only problems so number one is really
making a concerted consistent effort to
train your kids to be optimists that's
number one number two and this might
sound strange coming from me is coding
learning to code and I use coding even
though I'm not a coder because from what
I've seen in my friends and I know a lot
of friends who are programmers coders it
is a very very effective quickly
iterative way to develop structured
thinking and problem-solving using a
portable tool kit and every one of those
words I pick very
carefully and one way to think of it is
that good coders are good scientists
very good coders are very good
scientists they're good at trying to
replicate they're good at trying to
falsify they're good at applying
constraints and the best coders I've met
also search for elegance and find beauty
and code much like poetry there's a
certain economy that is respected I
would perhaps in a different age have
said science and science within the
confines of research or academia but
that could be very stifling and very
bureaucratic and I wouldn't want to push
her into that type of environment I
think that coding as a skill set is very
rapidly deployable it's mobile you do
not need an expensive lab or research
assistants for which you need to apply
to the NIH for grants and so on
to fund coding is very expedient very
practical so coding would be one I think
that would also teach efficiency and so
we have got optimism coding I don't code
I would like to learn to code or rather
put a better way learn is so sloppy it's
very very nebulous I would like to do a
coding bootcamp of some time I think it
would it would add some some connections
between synapses in my brain that would
be fun at the very least probably
exhausting and also beneficial given my
exposure to natural language so we've
got optimism coding and then the the
last one that I took a note on is music
and I initially put down art this is for
aesthetic appreciation and observation
developing skills of observation and I
remember speaking with Ed Catmull
president or at least then president of
Pixar on the podcast
and he went from I believe physics or
rather art to computer science he went
from art to computer science if I'm
getting if memory serves it correctly
and he said something along the lines
that people think that's a very strange
switch but it's not because I think it
was physics actually art physics in both
cases you are learning how to see
drawing is not how to move your hand it
is learning how to see painting is not
learning which colors to dip the
paintbrush in that's certainly a
downstream effect but ultimately you
need to be able to see so that would be
the benefit of visual art I think that
music also helps to cultivate perception
and awareness and paying attention it
happens to be auditory the reason I put
down music instead of art I could
certainly also have art but a lot of
people myself included
drop art after say high school or
college and my hope would be that I
could introduce my daughter in this case
to music that is collaborative rent some
type of music that she is able to use
with friends or in front of friends
around a campfire that type of thing so
that it travels with her throughout life
and unlike coding which can be very
solid derek is the next question when
all is said and done and it's lights out
for good what do you want people to
remember about you and what you've done
or going to do in essence what would you
want your eulogy to be I don't think all
too much about legacy to be honest I
mean I I focus on legacy but I don't
think much about it that might sound
strange but I try to do things that will
have some lasting impact but we
mentioned of all or I mentioned of all
earlier
he's also fond of asking and I think he
did this in our initial podcast it's
like how many Sumerians do you know how
many Babylonians do you know entire
civilizations viewed as the pinnacle of
achievement of humankind at the time
erased turned to dust
so I have no I have no delusions about
the persistence of of my legacy as such
but what would I want my you
to be something along the lines of he
created thousands or hopefully millions
of learners who are better than he was
that's it my goal with almost everything
I do is to try to make myself obsolete
as quickly as possible I want people who
read say the 4-hour body or tools of
titans or any of these books that have
what seem like outrageous examples of
doing a lot in very short periods of
time whether that's physical change
building companies or otherwise I want
readers to pick that up and do something
better and with with every book so far
from the 4-hour workweek all the way
through - rub mentors I've seen that
which makes me happy because that's my
goal so there you have it all right I'm
gonna answer one more on the submitted
questions and then we're gonna go to
live Q&A but first I'm gonna have a sip
of this wine and I'll show the label to
people who are here on video and then I
will read it for those who are joining
us maybe at some later date audio only
this is Zarate from it looks like la
palma de el Palomar
Palomar winery is albariño so quite nice
this is a gift and I'm diggin it so
there you have it Tim Ferriss drinking
white wine what the hell is the world
come to question from Brandon Beckett
and I'm gonna this is a long one so I'm
going to read it quickly you mentioned
briefly that you have lost some people
close to you recently I've been lucky
enough to not have lost many people but
a recent loss just utterly destroyed me
to the point where I was physically ill
for two months despite practicing
stoicism mindfulness and exercising I
really was not prepared for this and I
don't know how to prepare for it to
better handle it next time understand
this is personal enough fun to talk
about but my question is how do you deal
with losing someone close any tips
resources or personal stories an on
learning to handle loss that have worked
for you number one I would recognize
that it is
more than okay it is natural and I think
healthy to grieve in to mourn
so you shouldn't view that as a defect
of your character or a problem to be
solved necessarily and I say necessarily
because there are books and other things
that I think can give you perspective
that allow you to metabolize it perhaps
the loss of someone close in a more
fluid way the first is on grief and
grieving this is a book that was
recommended to me by Matt Mullenweg
after he lost his father that's a very
dear friend of mine lost his father very
unexpectedly and he wished he had read
the book before his father passed so I
think on grief and grieving that's the
title of the book is very useful for
preparing yourself for the inevitable
losses that you will face we're all
going to die it's morbid but it's
reality check that everyone you love
will die unless we happen to solve the
immunity immortality elixir sometime
soon which I would not bet on and
there's tremendous tremendous value
there's tremendous value in realizing
that because it increases the perceived
value of the time that you have left
with the people you care about there's
an essay I highly recommend called the
tail-end by Tim urban it really puts it
in perspective and I think the number
that's used is at least for Tim what he
noticed looking at average life spans
and so on
that if if he lives to be 90 years old
which is already pushing it and quite an
assumption and if his parents live long
enough that they are alive while he's in
the sixties I believe is how he put it
that by the time he graduated from high
school and left home he had spent 93
percent of all of the hours with his
parents that he would ever spend with
them in other words from the graduation
of high school until their deaths is 7
percent of the total hours that you will
spend with them and
really put things in perspective for me
so that that prioritized blocking out
time with family well in advance very
important spending money on that very
important if necessary and I would
surmise that many of the regrets people
have or the feeling of incompleteness or
life interrupted that they experience
when someone close to them dies is
because there are things they wanted to
say that they didn't say there are
things they wanted to be heard that
weren't heard and so on and the the
tail-end puts the timeline into such
perspective that it helped me to take
the initiative and and have a lot of
those conversations already with parents
with my brother with close friends and I
don't hesitate to say this sounds
perhaps cheesy to some people but love
you much love to you and yours love you
bro
I'm really happy that you're in my life
to friends and so on I'm I used to be
very sparing with the word love and I am
no longer that way the other piece which
I'm not advocating for I always have to
give this preface because I'm not a
doctor I don't play one on the internet
and I do not recommend you do anything
that is illegal in your jurisdiction but
psychedelic experience also I think
gives you a lens into what people may
experience when they die and if you look
at Imperial College of London they've
they've looked quite closely at the
comparison of intravenous DMT that's an
N dimethyltryptamine and near-death
experiences and they map very closely
I'm not recommending that you do IV DMT
by the way I think that one can and many
people have had experiences like that
under the influence of many of the
classic psychedelics there are risks
involved obviously but my past personal
experiences with some of these compounds
have led me to be much less worried
about dying which it turns out is a
rather common side-effect including with
patients who are suffering from
life-threatening diagnoses with cancer
for instance and that's the last piece
then I'll add to that and with that
let's jump into the live questions and
another simple wine
when is the next in-person meetup Vince
the short notice movie screening was
great for people in Austin but tough for
the rest of us I'm hoping to do more of
those as I travel around it's a lot of
fun
Robbie Wade what did you learn about
love since being in your latest
relationship how do you tackle society's
binary options
well binary options I kind of throw out
as as a matter of course it's very rare
when someone says you can do a or B that
that is true there's almost always a C
or a D or in a year and F option they
might not be options that are attractive
but there are always options so if you
don't like your situation you have
options you always have options you just
might not like those options but never
forget that you have agency you do have
options you do have the ability to
choose that's part one learn about love
I would say that this and this this
reminds me of the second point that Mike
maples jr. made to me about parenting so
number one you might recall I said
earlier while the teacher kids optimism
number two was remember that they don't
owe you anything
you chose to bring them into the world
not the other way around or I should say
they didn't ask you get super
metaphysical about this but they didn't
ask to be brought into the world you
brought them in they don't owe you
anything and their job is to receive
love not to give love and I think that's
what I've certainly learned for myself
is that for love to permeate my
relationship stay with my current
girlfriend the fastest way to get to a
saturation point where I feel like we
are you know in a constant flow of of
love that there's
a lot of the things with surface and in
the perceived absence of love and
security etc to prevent that all I have
to do is try to express love and feel
love and gratitude for love if I do
those things the receipt of love as
explicitly demonstrated by my girlfriend
becomes less important she's very
demonstrative anyway so I'm I'm in luck
with that but by doing all of those
things I can tangibly get the benefits
of love and not be dependent on being
given it in very obvious ways like an
oxygen mask I don't need the oxygen mask
if I focus on the giving maybe that is a
very dissatisfying answer but that's
that's the best I can do right now yob
you do I drink beer I don't drink beer I
have enjoyed beer in the past especially
when I was pretty poor and ended up in
Munich at one point and the the bottled
water was something like five euros and
the liters of beer were one so I drank
them even though I get a semi allergic
reaction but I don't drink much beer
these days all right
as my morning routine this is from gunas
I gotta potty has your morning routine
changed in recent times if so what's
what are the new additions yes it has it
has changed recently because I'm on book
deadline and when I am on book deadline
per Neil Gaiman on the podcast the
closer to Groundhog Day I can get with
my days the more productive I am
therefore my often lengthy morning
routines where I wake up and do the
meditation and the five-minute journal
and morning pages and so on and so forth
has been replaced with writing and I
really try to win the morning to win the
day
and this is something that I've heard
that could by Gary Keller who is
co-author of the one thing for instance
and many other people I these days wake
up much earlier than usual so I'm waking
up around 6:30 and I then throw on the
electric kettle to boil water
get it more or less to 190 so not
boiling then I go take my supplements
for the morning and come back the
water's ready to go
I take chaga chaga mushroom powder which
I have from 4 sig Matic and then a
teaspoon of soluble yerba mate a tea
from a brand I believe it's called Matt
Dale ale
Mitali only I was lying I'm sure
mangling that in Portuguese but it's
it's a soluble your Matta that I really
like then I mixed that together I have I
take that along with a thermos of hot
water and I walk to my outdoor patio
where I'm sitting right now with my
triangular wooden table she can see on
Instagram put it up in the last week or
so as my office and I immediately get to
work if I wake up earlier for some
reason I might do a 20 minute meditation
but otherwise I come right out and I
have a big whiteboard easel with my
chapters or writing pieces that I'm
working on for that day and I
immediately began working on the writing
that is ideally first on paper so I will
have printed out drafts that I worked on
the day before and I'll do editing on
paper and then I'll jump into the laptop
to make those edits and that goes from
say 6:30 to 9:30 or so maybe 10 o'clock
at that point I exercise and that could
take the form of a class that could take
the form of cycling that could take the
form of weight training generally
something endurance related also if the
weather's nice I'll get out into the Sun
that's from say 10 to 11:30 something
like that have lunch and then it is back
to writing and in the afternoon that
would be up until I would say five or
six taking a break every hour or so for
ping-pong for five minutes and I use it
a timer with one of my researchers will
play and then we wrap up around
say 7 o'clock dinner 7:30 whether at a
restaurant or cooking and dinner maybe a
sauna and a barrel sauna for say 10 to
20 minutes with cooling off in the pool
in between rounds bed with a more packed
dumb white noise machine and the
temperature set to maximum 70 degrees
bedtime
wake up rinse and repeat that's what the
day looks like to tiss I think tutus
tutus and toes do you believe in the law
of attraction and abundance thinking
this is a very fair question I believe
that the questions you ask yourself
create a lens through which you view the
world and that we all have selected
attention that there are different ways
to choose what you select to see much
like when you buy say a new car if you
happen to buy a could be anything a
Tesla a certain model Tesla chances are
you're gonna go driving and you will see
Tesla's everywhere you will now notice
all of the Tesla's that were already
there that you had just allowed to pass
through your vision unnoted before the
abundance thinking Law of Attraction
secret camp I think goes a little off
the rails when they posit that if you
simply put a mantra out into the world
or a vision board that all those things
are going to manifest automatically and
despite all the crazy [ __ ] that I talk
about and all the the psychedelic
experiences on that particular breed of
law of attraction magical thinking I
think is is very reckless and generally
unproductive but if you say look at the
four books I recommend at the back of
the 4-hour workweek as the four
fundamental reads or something like that
one of them is the magic of thinking big
by David Schwartz and
one could read that book and say what
wait a second this is all the stuff that
the law of attraction abundance thinking
people talk about it is and it is very
much focused on actionable next steps
and how you take that and translate it
into a plan that you can implement so I
I would say yes on one hand I do think
that abundance much like the book of the
same title by Peter Diamandis the
chairman of the XPrize is is a good
default setting looking for solutions
instead of complaining about problems
that's Molly my lovely pooch barking in
the background she's decided the barking
is really fun in the last few months so
abundance is a good default setting and
I do think as mentioned earlier that
training yourself for optimism has a
whole host I mean innumerable benefits
but the belief that you can put together
a vision board and that the world is
going to give you everything you want or
something along those lines
I think is not likely to pan out very
well so that's that let's see here
Andrew what's a good way to get your
network started if you've neglected it
for say 30 years question mark
I would I would Google how to build a
world-class network in record time which
is a presentation I gave at South by
Southwest that would tell you exactly
how would go about doing it Elian if I'm
getting your name right did I become
more nurturing since I got Molly yes I
would say absolutely and I become less
self-centered which i think is probably
the prerequisite not that I was a
complete [ __ ] beforehand I hope not
but we are all self-centered in the
sense that we focus on the self we are
the the lead actor or actress in our own
movie and having a dog for me at least
has forced me to constantly consider the
needs of someone or something outside of
myself
and it is also forced me to contend with
messes of all sorts my dog gets diarrhea
in the middle of night shits all over my
room which has happened I had to have
carpets removed it makes no sense for me
to get furious with my dog the dog
doesn't want to [ __ ] on the carpet Molly
doesn't she's not doing that to exact
revenge upon me she doesn't have thumbs
she can't open the door can't go outside
and spray-paint the the the nearby shrub
or whatever so it's also been a really
good mirror for me in the sense that I'm
able to look at my reaction to things
that are outside of my control that's
particularly helpful when you have dear
innocent Molly who would never
deliberately do anything to upset me or
anger me so it's it's been wonderful
practice and a wonderful practice I
should say and she's she certainly had a
a comprehensively wonderful effect on my
life but if you are thinking of getting
a dog number one please consider
adopting I've adopted Molly there are a
lot of dogs in the adoption and number
two is don't get a dog if your plan is
to fit it around everything else in your
life get a dog if you can say I'm gonna
get a dog and it's so important to me
that I help this dog have a wonderful
life and therefore help increase the
likelihood of me having a wonderful life
that I'm going to fit everything around
the dog I'm gonna change my schedule I
am going to I'm willing to change my
schedule I am willing to spend money I'm
willing to do that to ensure this dog
gets exercise and has the life I should
have and I've decided that that is the
big rock I'm putting in my jar and then
there are the smaller stones in the sand
but the dog goes in first it's not the
last thing that is left over and it gets
the table scraps of life that's my two
cents and if you want more on training
so on thinking about all this Susan
Garrett is a fantastic dog trainer and
also a spectacular
agility competitor with dogs was on the
podcast so you can find her she's
fantastic
she's just exceptional all right Jen
Daniel what did you do for Lyme disease
that's also a question that was in the
submitted questions that were selected
about my team so I'll answer that also
from Jen
so congratulations I saw both the short
answer is that I did a proper cycle of
doxycycline which is an antibiotic and
the mistake I made was that I waited for
symptoms to appear I spent time in a
number of locations that have incredibly
high tick density and they are the hot
spots on the CBC at the Center for
Disease Control Maps and I grew up in
one of those environments on Long Island
and the local belief was you get bitten
by tick you wait if you don't get a
bull's-eye rash you don't have Lyme
disease
if you do get a bull's-eye rash then you
go into the doctor and get medication
the problem is by the time you get a
bull's-eye rash you already have Lyme
disease similarly or I shouldn't say
similarly on the other side if you don't
show a bullseye rash that does not mean
you have not contracted Lyme disease
something like twenty or twenty to
thirty percent of the people who
contract Lyme disease do not display
some type of dermatological response
like that and I was one of those people
the doxy was I think necessary didn't
have a demonstrable effect on my
day-to-day living but ketosis did going
into ketosis and getting into deep
ketosis meaning say it at least two and
a half mil among the precision extra
device made by Abbott Labs was what like
that as soon as I got to say two
millimoles I felt like a different
person
and that brings up all sorts of
speculation and theories about what Lyme
disease might do to the brain is it
glucose metabolism when you give it an
alternate fuel source like
Ketones perhaps also say in the case of
Alzheimer's disease which some people
call brain diabetes you see this
dramatic in some cases in my case
cognitive shift where I felt like old
Tim for for all intents and purposes
overnight and staying in ketosis for a
few weeks and then coming back out to
lower carbohydrate for a few months was
what seemed to have saved me it could be
a regression to the mean and just the
passage of time I don't know but I have
seen ketosis have beneficial effects for
a number of close friends who've
contracted Lyme disease
one thing I will say is that Lyme
disease is very poorly understood and
there are often co-infections like BBC
OSIS and other things so it's it's it's
a really wily variable to figure out but
those are my thoughts or I shouldn't say
my thoughts
those are my experiences daniel campos
do you take any supplements medication
for anti-aging metformin nad etc I do -
I do
experiment with nad on occasion mostly
because that the penalty is very minor
side effects are very minimal metformin
I would consider I haven't used I have
used met form before glucophage but I
have not used it for many years I used
it way back in the day 96 that's when I
tried metformin for the first time so go
look at look at look at look at the
history books for that I was a long time
ago as far as metformin conversation
goes rapamycin would also be of interest
to me it's it's quite challenging to
figure out what type of human dose to
use for purposes of longevity and I'm
working on that or I should say rather I
have very close friends who are working
on that so I'm waiting to see what they
as the first monkeys shot in the space
figure out I'm happy to be the tenth or
hundredth monkey shot into space and not
the first which i think is a good policy
in general alright looking at some
comments here
after my mention of ketosis ash it looks
has had a similar experience with Lyman
ketosis going on the ketogenic diet as
per your interview with dom D'Agostino
help my symptoms especially the
neurological ones more than anything
else that was my personal experience -
no guarantees your mileage will vary but
there you go
Galvan Kennedy a few people have
suggested that I answer your question
any books or tips on breaking up with
long term underperforming business
partners this is a big topic I would say
take a look at hacker news venture hacks
venture hacks is probably a better
resource or at least easier to parse
that is a website created by navall Rob
can't feel like he's Candyman I keep
invoking his name navall rava cot rava
[ __ ] rava cot navall rava [ __ ] and his
friend nivi also behind Angeles and that
runs through what they wished they had
known when they were navigating the Star
Cup in the startup ecosystem and
breakups among co-founders is very
common as I would imagine they have
something written about that Crucial
Conversations
is a book that I've heard recommended
for navigating scripts or creating
scripts for this type of conversation
ultimately the break-up should ideally
be navigated quite easily because the
terms have been pre-decided in other
words if you're trying to figure out the
terms of your divorce agreement when
you're getting the divorce then you're a
one-legged man or woman and ass-kicking
contest you've you've really [ __ ] up
and I have [ __ ] this up before so I
speak from personal stupidity as well
but the the agreement that you craft and
you should always have an agreement with
a business partner is really only most
valuable for
disagreements and for the worst-case
scenario so you should have your
termination clause very carefully vetted
and if that has been carefully that then
the difficulty is more emotional and can
asking questions or conveying the desire
to break up than it is procedural or
legal right and so if the logistics the
process the the cost of breaking up with
them the terms have all been predefined
and you can certainly take that forward
into your next relationships then the
difficulty is primarily emotional and
and not related to the specifics of
implementation in which case I would
suggest that you read my next book I'm
working on a book about exactly this
type of stuff that I'm hoping will come
out in the next few months so I'll have
more on that soon but it literally was
just working on something related to
that today so I hope to have much more
to share in the meantime books like the
art of asking by meadow Palmer could
help you to find resources or mentors
people who could advise on this type of
conversation but for the low-hanging
fruit CFN tracks has something if not I
would suggest looking on Quora and
hacker news because there are so many
breakups among startup founders and
since the techies like to post and
publish and share you're just going to
find that sector over-represented online
so you might as well go fishing where
most fish are hanging out all right I'm
gonna do one more question here on the
live feed and then I am gonna go back to
the questions that you guys submitted
Phillip sierpinski how would you go
about overcoming an addiction if one is
a diagnosed sex addict how would you
approach it sex addict I can't speak to
specifically because I just I'm the more
I'm in the mores better camp with sex I
know that is probably very naive when
someone is genuinely sex addict
but can't speak to that specifically on
the topic of addiction however I would
say listen to my podcast with Gabor Ma
Tei dr. Gabor Matta hungarian-born
vancouver-based I believe still is an
expert in addiction and wrote a book
called in the realm of hungry ghosts but
if you watch my podcast with him gah bah
ga Bo AR ma te lastname
it's on YouTube as well and watch the
video which gets pretty uncomfortable at
points it's fun to watch I think that
conversation delves into addiction more
than any of my other podcast episodes I
would start there and then the resources
and so on recommended in that I think
will take you to places that will be
helpful question from Jared Rieger what
books do you men for someone right
before they're under major life change
first big job for me specifically we
pause for dramatic effect I would
recommend two books in the following
order the 80/20 principle by Richard
Koch KO CH and the second book how to
stop worrying and start living by Dale
Carnegie those are two great books
there's another one that I haven't read
in forever I think it's how to be a star
or how to be a star at work this is a
book that was actually given to all new
hires at a few companies I respected
when I graduated from college and 99 or
2000 I was on the five-year plan let's
not forget cuz I took a year off I found
that helpful at the time but I certainly
think that the three books I might give
you I'm gonna add one to the list would
be 8020 principle where Richard Koch
chaos eh how to stop worrying and start
living by Dale Carnegie and then a book
I've already mentioned in this Q&A the
magic of thinking big by David Schwartz
that's where I would start next question
and this one definitely deserves a sip
of wine so bear with this from Anthony
is a fellow balding man I'm interested
to hear about how you have processed
your hair loss mentally and
how much it did or did not affect you
you know I looked at this question and I
wasn't sure how helpful it would be but
here is the truth number one I have
probably more private messages DMS
social media notifications from men
agonizing over this than anything else
and number two is it was hard for me it
really was and in part because it caught
me really off-guard I remember it very
very specifically so if you got the
widow's piece right if you're losing
hair this way you can track it but I
never see the back of my head and that's
where I started and I remember very
clearly in 2004 I was in Germany for the
Z read the 4-hour workweek I went to
London then Ireland I bounced around I
ended up in Germany at one point and
that point I had hair was kind of spiked
sometimes slicked back
it's just a very Long Island haircut and
I remember hanging out with this German
family at a barbecue and someone took a
photograph of me from behind and it got
developed something like a week later
and I saw the photo and clear as day I
was losing my hair on the back of my
head and I had no idea and I really
didn't know what to do
it certainly bothered me and you know
for a while I would keep the hair keep
the hair keep there and fortunately in
high school and even before that as a
wrestler
I had shaved my head and I always found
a very convenient it never really
bothered me so there was a point where I
simply decided you know what I don't
want to be that guy who's coming over
his five bunches of hair on one side
each morning fooling himself but fooling
no one else I don't want to be that guy
I'm not into the the power donut look
and it simply came down to saying you
know what let me turn this this bug into
a feature and just shave my head and and
I will say this much that I don't think
I've never met a woman who's like I'm
into balding men
and again this is very blabbity blah
heteronormative guide a guy if you are a
heterosexual was worried about women
responding to your loss affair I've
never met a woman who's into balding men
who's like oh I love balding men I have
met a lot of women who are into bald men
right and that would be one sort of word
of Solace I would I would offer if
you're in that awkward in-between space
I did consider different drugs at one
point so minoxidil topical finasteride
other otherwise known as propecia I used
propecia for a little bit and it killed
my sex drive killed my sex drive and
affected my sexual performance and I
decided you know what all of this you
know all this fancy [ __ ] is if we're
really being honest with ourselves about
mating advantage and so for me
attracting women subconsciously most of
the time and being eager to have sex and
being able to have sex the way that I
like to have sex is more important than
trying to rescue the sort of clear-cut
remnants of what used to be on the top
of my head so I was like you know what
let me just call a spade a spade in for
a penny in for a pound let me take it
off and I've never really looked back
partially because I'm constantly on
video so if I suddenly showed up with a
brand-new spiffy afro or something like
that I would be heckled until my dying
day so I'm good with the bald I will I
will tell you this though and for those
of you on video you can see this the
cueball effect with this type of
reflection on your head is a real thing
and I would suggest then if you're doing
any media or anything like that that you
get a basic makeup kit this is I cannot
believe I'm talking about this too deep
glaze your head so that you don't blind
everyone who is looking at a photograph
or video of you and I learned on media
tours for book launches the head it is
naive to think that every place is going
to have their own hair and makeup to do
that for you
another pro tip related to that is that
if you have a girlfriend tell her about
your makeup kit before she finds it
because I've had the experience of
having a ridiculous little head D
buffing makeup kit which is not much
it's like ten bucks from a CVS and a
girlfriend terney be like who is she who
is she and it turns into a big [ __ ]
thing that you don't need to deal with
so if you're bald and you're just trying
to deglaze your donut head tell you're
going for an advance if you buy any
makeup
alright there are powders Kerry Bach I
don't know anything about makeup but I
know just enough to save people the
problem of glare when they're looking at
my head today I'm going on a trail
alright Wow people have a lot of brand
suggestions for deagle I think the good
Lord this is why you get paid the big
bucks folks having this type of
conversation on drinking wine out on my
back porch for [ __ ] sake what is this
world coming to
all right next question Rob Maliki mate
not trying to knock you off earlier or
anything but buried or cremated why and
where this is something I've been
thinking about in the last few days
actually yeah so it's it's a timely
question for a long time I thought about
and decided I preferred cremation
because it seemed final in some respect
that might be gratifying for anyone who
had survived me family members children
etc and it seemed to be less hassle for
everyone else who was left I've since
changed my mind about that I think that
I would like to be fed back to the earth
I think that it would be selfish of me
after consuming so many plants so many
animals so many resources as a human
being not to
for my body back to the earth to be
digested that might sound very strange
but I think in many respects that's a
beautiful continuation of the cycle so I
would want to be buried ideally without
a coffin that may be illegal in the
United States I suspect it is but I
would I would really like to be maybe
wrapped in a shroud and buried without a
coffin I think that would be a good way
to go
rich asks quote what is your current
opinion of staying in ketosis
perpetually do you think it's okay or
even better to stay in ketosis all the
time
or is it better to cycle in and out of
ketosis and that's from an overall
health slash longevity viewpoint not
weight loss there are better people to
ask about this dr. Dom D'Agostino with
whom I've done two podcasts on ketosis
would be 1 Peter Tia MD would be another
I think that ketosis doesn't sit well
with everyone or perhaps better put
following a ketogenic diet and Entering
dietary ketosis consuming 70 to 80
percent or more of your calories from
fat which often ends up including dairy
if you're not care careful which can
affect all sorts of biomarkers for
instance I'm very sensitive to any type
of dairy my lipid profile goes berserk
so I need to be very very calculated
with how I do ketosis it doesn't work
for everyone it doesn't sit very well
for everyone and you should follow the
report card your your blood work as an
indicator but there are many people who
stay in ketosis for long periods of time
I know people who stayed in for years I
think there are likely some health
benefits to that but what I can comment
on is your question of is it better to
cycle in and out of ketosis from an
overall health longevity standpoint not
weight loss my current understanding and
this is going to be a partial answer
your question is that one of the main
benefits of cycling in and out of
ketosis is to promote
Nabal ISM so if you want to build muscle
ketosis is actually a very suboptimal
state for building a lot of muscle if
you want to get big and strong you wants
insulin as a master hormone of sorts to
help store nutrients and trigger muscle
growth hypertrophy and so on the way you
can accomplish that dan duchesne tu CH
AI n e Mauro DiPasquale I believe is how
he said his name the anabolic diet have
designed various diets all of which you
could consider cyclical ketogenic diets
CK DS and that generally entails ketosis
from say let's call it Monday to Friday
then a glycogen depletion work out on
Saturday followed by carb loading let's
just call it that for 18 hour period
something like that then slowly cycling
back into ketosis and in some cases
using tools to accelerate that like
alpha lipoic acid or other things I
would not suggest injecting insulin
unless you have doctor supervision and
really want to play Russian roulette and
that is a dangerous one but CKD gives
you a window of high insulin response
and carbohydrate loading to promote
muscle growth so if you want performance
the CKD in and out of ketosis I think it
could be plausibly recommended if you're
looking for straight longevity which
which I don't make a a sole focus of
mine that is staying alive for the
maximum number of years
going in and out may not be the ideal
path but do you really want to stink
ptosis your whole life or even for years
at a time it gets boring as hell and you
can you can eat all the ketosis friendly
junk foods that have been created but
you're eating also a lot of crap that
isn't terribly nutrient-dense in most
cases so it's really a question in my
mind a functional health span and Peter
Tia has talked about this at some length
so I would suggest taking a look at my
podcast with Peter Tia there at least
two of them he is brilliant and
methodical and obsessive-compulsive
which is exactly what you want in a
doctor studies such things alright I'm
gonna do some more live questions I know
we're 15 minutes over time and that's
okay I'm gonna go a little long for you
guys because I love you [ __ ] and this
is fun I'm having a good time
so it's laughing at some of these
comments you guys are hilarious
alright quick question Michelle Martina
I struggle to fast because my heart
races any ideas yeah this is a
cholinergic response as I understand it
and you can supplement with or I have
found I'll speak from personal
experience that's supplementing with
electrolytes for instance taking slow
mag which is magnesium throughout the
day as well as potassium sodium you
could get an electrolyte supplement like
noon and uun as long as you ensure that
there are no calories associated with it
but electrolytes can help quite a bit
all right let's see looking for some
more live questions how did you decide
to give us back our donations and give
us Amazon gift cards because one of my
goals for did a quarterly off-site with
my team we two months ago and reiterated
that one of the goals was to surprise
one of the primary goals that I have is
to surprise and delight my fans and I
thought about how to do that and in the
case of the supporters so they're a few
thousand of you who supported the
podcast and everything else for the
short-lived fan support experiment
I figured what the hell I can afford it
and it's fun it's something nobody does
that I'm aware of I've never heard of a
single instance so if somebody gave me
nine ninety-five a month and they got
charged for two months I'm gonna refund
their twenty bucks and then I'm gonna
give them an additional twenty four
Amazon they can use for anything and by
the way anyone who's international you
can still use the amazon.com website to
order but have it shipped to where you
are and if they donated a hundred or a
thousand a month same thing so there are
some people who donated a thousand a
month they got charged for two months
they got two thousand dollars back and
then two thousand dollars in additional
Amazon gift cards from from me and my
team you know life is [ __ ] short and
I thought it's not gonna break the bank
I want a reward my one thousand true
fans or several thousand true fans the
one thousand true fans is an expression
borrowed from Kevin Kelly if you haven't
read that essay I suggest you do at KK
org one thousand true fans it's easy for
me to do I thought it'd be fun I thought
it would surprise people and hopefully
delight people and then when you go to
Amazon and buy whatever you're gonna buy
over the next handful of months you'll
also be like oh yeah gift cards Tim
Ferriss so it's it's like having a
little jack-in-the-box with my shiny
bald head popping up going thank you
every time you go to em son and the gift
card balance reminds you that I sent it
to you
I saw no downside and a lot of fun and
upset from it so that's how I decided to
do it people are still sending me advice
for products that I can use on my shiny
bald head
what else do galvan can you get Neil
deGrasse Tyson on the show I would love
to I actually met him for the first time
last week I went to a live taping of
Startalk it was awesome Neil is an
incredible guy if you haven't seen his
podcast you should check it out or the
TV show or anything he does he's just
hilarious and awesome and a lot of fun
anything special planned for podcast
number 400 no not right now I haven't
thought about it I probably should give
him the for shtick that I've somehow
made a career out of looking for more
questions
Robbie Wade what do you think of the
saturation of masterminds and coaches I
think you should pay attention to people
who have done what they're teaching
that's it and can prove it so I would
really there there are many people out
there who teach and not and don't do or
teach because they can't do or worse
still misrepresent and claim that
they're making six figures a month or a
year or whatever and are really just
preying upon people because there's no
means of verification so I would say
that caution is the better part of valor
when it comes to two coaches choose your
influences very carefully I mean I've
mentioned many many many times but one
of my favorite quotes is you're the
average of the five people you associate
with most and if that is true if we take
that to be true if you're taking advice
from anyone who hasn't done what they
are preaching you are compounding all
sorts of problems and I would simply say
if you're looking at a mastermind or a
coach you should ensure that you can
verify whatever they are claiming they
have done is true that's it and that
will eliminate 95% of them out there
what are my thoughts on Roo meet sette
SE thi he's a close friend ver meets
super legit I've always been very
impressed to them he's very very good
scripts for negotiating and he walks the
talk I mean the guy knows what he's
doing and I've seen his life I've met
his family meaning his wife and his
brother and so on I've I've seen behind
the curtain and I found him very legit
I've never engaged with any of his
products or anything like that so I
can't speak to any of his courses or
anything along those lines but room meat
walks the walk so
I would I would say that he is a very
legitimate but I'm not owning any of his
mailing lists or anything like that
I've no idea how many email he sends out
no clue all right Ryan how long did it
take you to be consistently happy
throughout your day-to-day life
are you still working on it I think
trying stressing out about being happy
every day will make you really unhappy
and there are a number of quotes out
there that are along the lines of if you
want to be happy stop striving for
happiness I think there's there's
there's quite a bit of wisdom to that
and there's another one I think it's the
RO might be Emerson I always confuse
those two they were buddies also which
doesn't make it any easier but that if
you if you stop searching for happiness
and sit down every once in a while
happiness like a butterfly will land on
your shoulder something like that
but obsessing about happiness is a great
way to be unhappy so I think more about
excitement and a feeling of purpose than
I do happiness and that is because
energy state emotional reactivity are
all in flux yesterday for instance just
yesterday it was a very difficult day
for me I had as I described earlier my
morning routine my plan was to write for
a good three or four hours and I had a
bunch of household emergencies a number
of technicians and carpenters and
electricians show up I have guests in my
house and there were a number of things
that required my attention that pulled
me out so I didn't get my writing done
in the morning and it made me very very
agitated made me very agitated and the
the whole day was just a shitshow of
distraction and fire drills in the
afternoon I was like I'm gonna make it
up I'm gonna get in my hours and then lo
and behold no dice the universe had
other plans and it was just a mess so
yesterday I was I was in an emotional
toddler and my my skin was very thin and
the buffer that I had that would
normally allow me
you take a chill pill not overreact to
things was worn thin today totally
different story today I was able to
follow my routine I do like my routine
and suspicions and deadlines
that's not unusual and got a good solid
three four hours in the morning got a
lot done and honestly after that point
everything else was gravy I also got
exercise twice today so that was a win I
don't stress about being consistently
happy in everyday day-to-day because
that is just a recipe for unhappiness in
my experience all right here's the quote
that I was looking for from Carolyn
Nichol drunk - I guess I don't know what
the tones are on that that's probably
how you'd say that in Chinese Zi hua ng
Zhi drunk sure plunger who knows
happiness is the absence of the desire
for happiness that is really worth
sitting on and contemplating there's a
lot there's a lot to pull from that Jay
Bell who are the strongest female voices
mentors inspirations in my life while
not sound cheesy but I did this dedicate
my hello wine dedicate I did desiccate
desiccates my neighbor for my mother no
I did dedicate my first book to my mom
and dad my mom taught me very early that
marching her own drummer was a good
thing and didn't have the resources to
buy a lot of new things but had the
creativity to expose me and my brother
to a lot of things so say if we eat
chicken legs for dinner which we did a
lot maybe we ate a handful of meals over
and over nori and TV dinners chicken
legs so we had chicken legs let me take
the chicken legs and there'd be a little
bit of meat or fat gristle on these
these bones and she'd saved those and
then the next day or that weekend we
would take these bones and go to a pond
where I guess was the bay where we could
tie a string around those bones and drop
them into the water and pull them out
with crabs and sea crabs look at them
etc collect black sand using magnets and
put them in
and play with them so she's very good at
feeding curiosity and then supporting
interests with books we didn't have a
budget for much but we always had a
budget for books which is brilliant line
by the way
so my parents told me that my mom
especially and that made us my brother
and I think about books books where this
thing to be coveted they were not
homework right there were there was
something to be coveted something we
desired something we wanted the other
main influence we my girlfriend she's
she's an excellent excellent
communicator and one of the most
self-aware people I've ever met and she
has shown me in many respects what being
nonreactive looks like if you're hearing
a weird noise out in the distance that's
because I am on an outdoor patio and
that is a gigantic owl so I would say my
mom and my girlfriend primarily those
would be the two mains I'll stick with
that for now have a lot plenty of female
friends but those are the two mains
right and my fan of Rick and Morty yes I
am a huge fan of Rick and Morty what's
my favorite cryptocurrency resources you
know I don't I try not to think about
cryptocurrency much I do have money in
cryptocurrency but I delegate the
decision-making to other people because
I have no confidence in my ability to
operate in that sandbox with any type of
advantage all right all right so I'm
gonna I'm gonna tackle this comment or
comment on it just because I I suppose I
feel like putting a bull's-eye on my
forehead comment is need more women on
the podcast I'll tell you what I need on
the podcast I need on the podcast good
people no matter what their genitalia
look like no matter what their preferred
or stated gender is no matter what their
race is who have a lot of tactics to
share
I don't think about preferably choosing
men and I also don't want to think about
trying to recruit women period as
a criterion at the top of the hierarchy
I don't think that I don't think about
gender when I'm recruiting I guess at
all and I like it that way it's it's not
a factor I just had a woman on the
podcast you know we this earlier this
week and there were a lot of women in my
books tribe mentors was like 50/50 but I
think that identity politics is a losing
game if we if we read any history that
should be very clear and they're there I
should be able to learn from a smart
woman as much as a woman can learn from
a smart man and I do think that that has
historically been the case for me and
you know Julie rice would be a great
example and I'm hoping to spend more
time with her who's been on the podcast
co-founder of SoulCycle and it doesn't
even enter my mind as a consideration
and I don't want it to become a
preoccupation but yeah I get it look I
totally understand that that if you're a
woman or if you are a film blank that
ideally you would have exemplars people
who can inspire you who remind you of
yourself in a sense but I would also
hope that we're all striving to look for
what we can learn from every person we
encounter and define the common ground
so there you have it
there there are more women coming there
are more women scheduled but I don't
want to apply some artificial constraint
or to make gender preoccupation because
it's it just isn't and I don't want that
to be alright let's see here oh boy
our kids in the cards we want a little
Ferris well we'll see about that
I'm I'm more interested in kids and I am
in the legal institution of marriage I'm
not super excited about having the state
or federal government involved with my
interpersonal affairs
well yeah I've been thinking more and
more about it so we shall see we shall
see how is moving Texas affected your
life lifestyle friendships as from
Montgomery all better everything's
better I mean I don't know what to say
aside from Austin is the friendliest
place I've ever lived and I expect to be
there for a long time alright what else
we have here
Ryan combs tips for determining whether
one is better suited for
entrepreneurship as in running a company
or freelancing more solo work start with
freelancing see how you like that if you
don't like freelancing you're definitely
not gonna like running a company so
start with that dude in that order right
what was it like to meet Ralph Potts
I've met Ralph a bunch Rolf is hilarious
he's a fun guy for those who don't know
Rolf Potts wrote a book called
vagabonding I think the subtitle is an
uncommon guide to the art of long-term
world travel something along those lines
and it is certainly about travel but
more broadly about a philosophy of life
and improvisation that Roth Potts
describes very poetically it's a great
book and had a huge impact on me that is
that is one of the four fundamental
reads at the back of the 4-hour workweek
I mentioned one already the magic of
thinking big by David Schwartz and
vagabonding is yet another and I enjoyed
back money so much I actually reached
out to Ralph to produce the audiobook of
vagabonding which you can find I believe
at audible.com forward slash Tim's books
I used to have a book club an audio book
club just for the fun of it cuz I want
extra projects to occupy all my time all
right this question from Matt what do
you think about the legal benefits of
marriage I think it's unfair that
married people get a tax benefits over
single co-living
yeah I think it's [ __ ] ridiculous
yeah period full stop
alright would I go to Mars well as as
Jeff Bezos has put it you know before
you go to Mars spend a few years in
Antarctica and see what you think
because Antarctica is a cakewalk
compared to Mars so I don't know I don't
know I think I think I might prefer
some type of Elysium like habitat more
than Mars and as Jeff Bezos put it - a
friend of mine he feels at least that
Mars is a bad idea and the last thing we
need after conquering or I should say
escaping Earth's gravity is to deal with
another gravity in another atmosphere
terraforming all that is very very very
very complicated I mean look at what
we've done on the moon first and then
consider where you think we will go with
Mars but hey the more options the
merrier so I'm glad people are looking
at it I read are you able to sleep
soundly when you're not alone in bed
it's tough actually hey I over heat very
easily so having somebody laying on top
of me is difficult but if I'm not in
twined with someone else I do find it
quite easy to sleep as long as my
temperature is regulated I don't have
too many issues from Jay Bell do you
feel you're making progress on healing
childhood trauma hope you continue to
share that journey yes I'm gonna be
sharing a lot about that and the book I
discussed with Greg McEwan author of
essentialism which is a great book so my
episode with him McEwen is MC ke o WN
focused on a book about healing which
would be related to many things
including this child to trauma which I
haven't gone into details about but some
bad stuff some bad stuff so I absolutely
plan on writing about that and I think
along with the blog post some practical
thoughts on suicide that'll be the most
important thing I've ever written that's
the hope I want to do it right Kari do
you think it would be valuable to have
those who have attempted suicide to talk
to those who have lost family to suicide
yes I do
question from Ryan did you always have
something in your life you were excited
about pursuing absolutely not I've had
long periods of anhedonia inability to
feel pleasure about anything at all so
no that's that's not a constant that's
something that I've had to work for and
work towards it's it's very much been
practice it's not something that comes
naturally to me at all times
Ryan question Tim I do - how do you
battle anhedonia I would recommend you
to look up the name George Sarlo SAR L o
on Vice and obviously follow all
regulations where you live and find a
professional to help
hikami therapy could also be very
interesting to look at which is a
somatic ie
body or physical based practice that
it's similar to mindfulness and I know
Hakone professionals will say that I'm
mangling this but it's a good enough
description that it is a type of therapy
that helps you to become more aware of
what you are feeling in your body and I
found it very valuable personally and
that I think could help you to tune in
to frequencies that will ultimately lead
you to overcoming anhedonia Jacob are
you building any new habits right now if
yes what's your process waking up early
and my process is scheduling my day so
that if I don't wake up early I don't
get my writing done I have to wake up
early I have to wake up between 6:30 and
7:00 or I'm not going to have the
critical block of time along the lines
of the makers schedule versus managers
schedule that Paul Graham is written
about fantastic essay for those of you
who have not read it Ellie on Tim are
you ever afraid you will slip back and
depression yeah for sure yeah it comes
up and what I've tried to do is accept
that that's going to happen and to
identify less with it to make it more I
am feeling depressed or there is a
feeling of depression versus I am
depressed and the book awareness by
Anthony de Mello de mal ello if you're
gonna read one book of all the books
I've mentioned in this QA pick up
awareness by Anthony de Mello there are
many chapters that help with what I'm
describing all right I'm gonna answer a
handful of additional questions it's
9:45 roughly so we've gone 45 minutes
over time I'll go for
a little bit more and then I think after
all this talk of my girlfriend I want to
go find my girlfriend and possibly do a
barel sona before bedtime since I do
have more writing tomorrow morning
Ranjit what Neal Stevens book do you
like other than Snow Crash Neal
Stephenson's great that's any al Neil
Stevenson Snow Crash is is amazing but
you already mentioned Snow Crash let's
skip Snow Crash and I would say Krypton
nomicon genomic on is a gigantic book
and it's not everyone's cup of tea but
it found me at the right time I suppose
I just absolutely loved Krypton abakan
so that would be my recommendation a
skiing or snowboarding skiing most of
the time snowboarding on Powder Jacob
the question what would you be or go to
activity experience for a first date if
your objective is to get to know someone
quickly hmm
Oh take them out to dinner and I would
well coffee date if it's like a first
screening but if you think someone is is
it is a decent prospect dinner and then
I would say right up front you know
please order whatever you want
this is on me and you can see how they
respond to that and I would still into
pain but it's I find it informative to
see how someone responds to just that
opener right so that you're not covering
that at the end of the meal it's been
covered in the beginning and then you
could ask you could say yeah I went to a
retreat this is true for me once you're
a treat and as a as a getting to know
everyone exercise they they had us go
around in a circle and each person would
say if you really knew me you wouldn't
know dot dot dot and they would fill
that in and so you do that with the
person you're with all right so if you
really knew me you would know that and
then you offer something and you're like
alright what about you then she goes or
he goes or whatever and then you say
alright so you've done that the next
step is if you really really knew me you
would know that dot dot dot and you do
that and you can get some really deep
really rarely heard stuff very quickly
with
so that that might be one approach in
terms of activities rock climbing
suppose I'm grasping for straws on that
what is your earliest childhood memory
my earliest childhood memory is of being
an infant and my parents had rented
their house to make money at one point
some some women in the background
my parents had rented their house for
income at one point and we're living in
a tiny cottage and I was there the
firstborn and had a horrible fever and I
was being cooled down in a sink and
screaming my face off and looking at the
ceiling and seeing devils and demons and
monsters on the ceiling that is my
earliest memory how [ __ ] awful is
that but at least up to this point that
appears to be the earliest memory go
figure
I'm not gonna end this Q&A on that
though what a [ __ ] downer that would
be all right
nice Stephen Stephen Hicks I teach at
medical school what is the best way to
expose a high performer who's never
failed at something to the concept of
failure without destroying their
confidence it's a great question I would
say have them write something and it
could be a report it could be an
analysis could be anything and at least
for say three rounds just say this isn't
good enough I would have expected more
from you here take this back and do
better and do that two or three times
and see and then talk to them do a post
game analysis and talk to them about
that after the fact
it's from ash thank you for everything
Tim what are you grateful for I'm
grateful for everything honestly it's
there's there is happiness and success
all around you and I realized I'm in a
very privileged and lucky position
there's not the same thing but I'm in
both and just the fact that I can sit
comfortably and do this just the fact
that I can see this screen just the fact
that I can taste this wine just the fact
that I have
people who are willing to read what I
write or listen to what I record for
this podcast or the fact that I can hear
the crickets and the owls and so on
around me that I am close to nature I
have access to nature I mean all these
things are are miracles in a sense and
it's certainly one the birth lottery I
mean I was born white male in the United
States and there's a lot that goes with
that but I I think about my parents
dying I think about the likelihood of
them dying in the next five years 10
years I think about the tail-end the
essay by Tim urban that I recommended I
think about how much I would pay after
my dog has died Molly to play with her
on the front yard here where I'm sitting
with some type of chew toy and to watch
her as happy as could be what would I
pay after she died she's gonna die
before I do
at least barring any type of unforeseen
disaster on my part after she dies two
years afterwards or a year afterwards a
month afterwards how much would I pay
this is from Moonee Valley actually in
tribe mentors to experience that to
re-experience say sitting in hammock and
throwing balls for molly a lot okay a
lot of money a lot of money I mean a an
absurd amount of money I think about
these things to cultivate gratitude it's
easy to become an ungrateful [ __ ]
it really is it's it's extremely easy to
become an ungrateful [ __ ] especially if
you spend too much time on social media
where the sport of choice is complaining
and bitching and moaning and talking
about lack and scarcity and entitlement
more than anything else it's a very
poisonous atmosphere and if you are the
app the average of the five people you
associate with most well we could chunk
that down into hours right so forget
about five people which groups are you
spending the most time with you spending
more time with Twitter than with
or two or three closes friends who'd be
a positive impact on you if so the trend
line isn't going in the right direction
from my perspective so I'm grateful for
a lot I'm grateful for so much and on
that I think we're gonna wrap up guys I
think that's a good place to wrap up I
have a lot of love for all of you it's
incredible that I get to do this as some
semblance of a job I'm very very lucky
and I will continue to do all that I can
to put together podcasts and books and
so on that allow you hopefully not just
to replicate what I've done but to do so
much more than what I've done and what I
may ever do that's my goal and with that
thank you all very much and have a
wonderful wonderful weekend many
blessings to you and yours
thank you again hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
for me would you enjoy getting a short
email for me every Friday and that
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
comm that's four hour work week com all
spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books I've been talking about fresh
books for years now we've all in one
invoicing payments and accounting
solution many entrepreneurs I know as
well as many contractors and freelancers
I work with all the time and use it all
the time so I get to see fresh books on
a weekly basis fresh books makes it
super easy to track things like expenses
project time and client info and then
merge it all into great-looking invoices
fresh books can save users up to 200
hours per year on accounting and
bookkeeping tasks I don't know about you
but I like to do as little of that as
possible so 200 hours is a lot of hours
first books is always releasing new
features that make running your business
easier and the here just few of the
major upgrades they've made in the last
12 months alone number one they've
redesigned the time tracking feature to
create a more intuitive time tracking
experience number two they know just how
frustrating bank reconciliation can be
so they've automated bank reconciliation
removing the pain number 3 they've added
ACH bank transfers that means you now
have an even faster way to collect
payment from your clients it's easy to
see how freshbooks
can grow with your business and also
help your business grow just gives you
more time to focus on growing the
business is supposed to running the
business and the admin stuff they have
plans to match your needs no matter the
size your business from the basic to
comprehensive from small to big and it
all starts at just 15 dollars per month
right now they're offering it my
listeners that's you guys a free 30-day
trial of fresh books you can try it out
with no credit card no credit card is
required just go to fresh books.com
slash tim and enter tim ferriss it's two
hours two S's in the how did you hear
about us second that's fresh ebooks.com
slash it's him and enter tim ferriss in
the how did you hear about us section
check it out fresh books calm slash tim
this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn jobs hiring can be hard can be
super super expensive and very painful
if you get her wrong I certainly have
had that experience multiple times
submit a lot of mistakes I am NOT eager
to repeat any of them so I try to do as
much vetting as possible now on the
front end today with more qualified
candidates than ever but certainly more
noise than ever
employers need a hiring solution that
helps them find the right people for
their businesses without wasting time
without wasting money LinkedIn jobs
provides just that Lincoln jobs screens
candidates with the hard and soft skills
that you specify that you're looking for
so you can quickly find and hire the
right person they also look beyond work
skills so collaboration creativity
adaptability to connect you with
candidates who match your business
perfectly they have mirrorless endless
business specific data points that help
them to massage this and that which can
help you to find the best fit LinkedIn
to make sure your job post gets in front
of people you want to hire people with
the skills qualifications and other
insights that help LinkedIn paint a
better picture of potential candidates
it's no wonder that great candidates are
hired every eight seconds on average on
LinkedIn that's pretty wild every eight
seconds
so find the right person meant for your
business today with LinkedIn jobs you
can pay what you want in the first fifty
dollars is on LinkedIn just visit
LinkedIn calm slash temp for more
details
again that's LinkedIn calm slash Tim to
get $50 off your first job post check it
out
linkedin.com slash Tim Terms &
Conditions to apply
[Applause]